You know what happens when you hold your pee?
Urine trouble!
Who is writing these?!
Hey pee-pees, Jules here for DNews.
We’ve all been there.
You’ve had too much to drink in too short
a time, your bladder feels like it's about
to burst but… oh no!
You’re DJing your cousin’s quinceanera
and they just requested the Cha Cha, so you
can’t go anywhere for a while!
You’re just gonna have to hold it.
Maybe you’ll do a little pee dance like
you’re Pelvis Presley, or try to distract
yourself, but ultimately, you have to pee.
So, just how bad is that for you?
Should you wait it out to avoid embarrassment?
Or should you bail on your prima’s 15th
birthday to relieve yourself?
Well, it really depends, unless you’re literally
wearing Depends and then it doesn’t matter.
The average adult pees about four to seven
times a day, because the average adult bladder
can really only hold about sixteen ounces
worth of liquid before feeling the urge to
purge.
At night, your bladder can hold up to twice
that before signaling that you have to pee,
which is why waking up to pee like a racehorse
is a pretty common experience.
But every body is different, and the amount
of bladder fullness necessary to feel the
pee reflect changes based on how hydrated
you are, the actual size of your bladder,
and most importantly, your bladder sensitivity.
See, when your bladder fills up, stretch receptors
along your bladder walls send a signal through
your spinal cord up into your brain.
In response, your brain sends back a “reflex”
signal, telling the detrusor muscle in your
bladder to contract, which squeezes your bladder
and creates an even stronger stretch reflex.
This feedback loop is what makes you have
to pee.
Your internal bladder sphincter, which is
a muscle that is normally tightened against
the intersection of your urethra and bladder,
opens up and is ready to let loose.
But hold on a second, if that’s all there
was to it, we’d have no control over our
urination.
Luckily, there’s something in the way.
The external sphincter, which is the last
line of defense against pee pants.
As long as our external sphincter, also called
the “distal sphincter” is healthy and
functional, you can technically hold your
pee forever.
But you won’t.
See, holding your pee in is kind of like an
unstoppable force going against an immovable
object.
Either your external sphincter or your detrusor
muscle are going to win the fight, and spoiler
alert: unless you’ve had bladder cancer,
or bladder surgery, or if you’ve had a Radical
Cystectomy with an Orthotopic Neobladder,
which is when doctors remove your bladder
and replace it with a new one made out of
your small intestines… if none of those
things apply to you, then your detrusor muscle
is going to win.
You’re gonna pee alllll over yourself.
Otherwise, if your bladder is structurally
weak, it can rupture against the seal of your
external sphincter, filling your abdomen with
urine that will have to be cathetered out.
So if you’ve got a healthy bladder then
nothing to worry about except peeing yourself,
right?
Wrong.
What you should be worried about are urinary
tract infections.
See, instead of thinking of your bladder like
a five star hotel swimming lounge, it’s
kind of more like a dirty pond.
The longer you let the pond stagnate, the
more likely it is to build up bacteria, which
can result in a urinary tract infection.
That’s almost certainly E. coli.
And besides being an infection down there,
which is already unpleasant, it can also cause
you to feel like you have to pee when your
bladder is empty!
So, in a way, if you keep holding your pee,
you’ll end up feeling like you have to pee
FOREVER!!!
The other side effect of regularly holding
in your pee is called “urinary retention”
which is when your detrusor muscle is unable
to fully evacuate the bladder.
So every time you pee, you don’t get it
all out.
Here’s the point: holding your pee is natural,
and we do it pretty much every single night.
In any single case, for a healthy adult, holding
your pee isn’t too big of a deal, and in
the worst case scenario, you’ll probably
just pee yourself.
But if you already have bladder issues, or
if you regularly refuse to pee when your body
demands it, then you’re very much at risk
of developing a UTI, or another inconvenient
medical problem.
You could even burst your bladder in some
cases.
So, do yourself a favor, pee freely and don’t
get pissed off.
Remember: peeing is #1.
And while you’re chilling, think of all
the time you’ve wasted not working on your
beach bod.
But don’t get too depressed, it’s not
too late because there’s Beachbody On Demand.
Check them out online at DNewsBOD.com, where
you can get access a wide variety of workout
programs including the world-famous P90X,
Insanity, Focus T25, and many others.
Sign up for Beachbody On Demand today and
get a FREE 30-Day Membership.
So if you're healthy, hold in your pee or
don't, I don't care.
But what about your poops?
Now that's something I care about.
If you do too, watch this video to find out
more.
So when was the last time you peed your pants,
I know I did just 10 minutes ago.
Let us know down below in the comments and
don't forget to like and subscribe for more
DNews every single day.